women who achieved something in their
lives and got somewhere have a
responsibility to educate the next
generation I would love my music to be
something that would entertain while
giving moments of thought people because
that's something that music to me my
name is Noah eras I'm a musician
electronic singer songwriter producer
from Israel there is a very very strong
feminine voice in electronic music here
a lot of women in tel-aviv are badass
Israel has been secured inspiration and
a topic in my music because of what's
happening here absolutely
I'm living with in this conflict
constantly I wake up in the morning to
this conflict and when something happens
I feel a part of it I talked about my
government a lot I talk about
politicians in general and people who
have power to make things better and
don't always do the right thing about it
others of us knowing that I'm feeling
that I'm in the middle of this is also
something that creates an inner conflict
I mean am i involved enough am i doing
enough in order to change things music
has always been a way for me to deal
with what happening around me what's
happening in the world and what's
happening inside me and it's the best
form of communication that I know from
me to the outside world
[Music]